Yeah,
double take magazine once printed a
little pamphlet,
which I listed 10 different things that
you should,
you should do.
I can't remember all of them,
but the first one was turned off the
television set.
I don't think you can,
you can read poetry while you're
watching television very well.
The idea of how to read a poem is based
on the idea that,
uh,
that poetry needs you as a reader,
that the experience of poetry,
meaning and poetry is a kind of circuit
that takes place between a poet,
a poem and a reader,
and that meaning doesn't exist,
or inherent poems alone that readers
bring their own experiences,
their own range of their own wisdom,
their own knowledge,
their own insights to poems and the
meaning of a poem takes place in the
negotiation between the poet,
the poem and the reader.
And then as a reader,
you have a task to do.
You have something to do.
You bring your experience to it.
It's not all inherent in the poem.
Um,
the great Holocaust post-holocaust poet
Paul Salon,
said that a poem is a message in a
bottle sent out in the not always
greatly hopeful belief that somewhere
and sometime it would wash up on land on
heartland.
Perhaps the idea of a poem is a message
in a bottle means that it's sent out
towards some future reader.
And the reader who opens that bottle
becomes the address.
See of the literary Text Salon was
picking up something that the Russian
poet Osap Manuel Stem had written in
1916 called on the address.
See.
And Mondo stomp says a poet,
you go down to the shore and you see an
unlikely looking from a bottle from the
past.
You open it,
model stem says it's okay to do so.
I'm not reading someone else's mail.
It was addressed to ever found it.
I found it,
therefore it's addressed to me and that
when you find it,
you become the secret address.
See of a literary text.
And I felt that,
um,
the reader had been left out of this
experience of reading poetry or what
rate or what the experience of poetry
was.
And so my focus is on the reader and
that the poets job is not to inspire
himself or herself.
The Post job is to inspire some future
reader.
And so as a reader,
you have a task to do in finding those
bottles and opening up the messages and
experiencing what's in them inside of
yourself.
I think that's a connection that you can
only hope for.
It's not something that you can make
because it does,
you know,
it needs someone else.
Um,
I find in,
in Walt Whitman and an American
tradition,
a certain kind of,
I would say desperate American
in which you reach out
in which the poet tries to reach out
through the page to make a connection by
the side of the road with some other
person.
But ultimately that's,
that's a longing,
not a completion that has to be made by
other readers.
You can see clarity,
you can seek warmth,
you can try to make something for
lasting.
You can pick something in salt so that
it's well made and you can hope that it
out last time.
But ultimately that's not up to you.
Ultimately,
you're trying to reach across and find
some other person,
some other human warmth,
but it is,
especially in written poetry.
It is inscribed and attacks and the text
can't do that.
Work by itself and you as a poet can
only do your best.